well I think that China has a great
potential to pull us out of the economic
crisis and I've learned a great deal
about Chinese civic society in the last
few days and in fact I believe that it
is civic society and all work going on
in the area of social innovation that
has a great potential and the rest of
the world will be able to learn from
China on besides I believe that what
China can keep the rest of the world and
which will contribute to pulling us out
of the crisis is China's literature
especially the classical literature
confusions and Taoism and Buddhism which
all these philosophies are reflected in
chinese people's approach to life in
respect to others respect to work and
the high values which chinese people
implement in their everyday lives thank
you